isn't it really slow baseball like it's
at least in america right they have like
an ad break after like every throw
yeah i don't know i don't know
exaggerating that's what it feels like
watching
i don't know i don't know it just feels
like one of those really boring sports
to watch
i'm gonna piss off a lot of baseball
fans now also okay well if we're pissing
off people
dude american football is so [ __ ]
boring and
they actually do have an ad every time
anything happens
okay okay it's so annoying okay let's
okay
i'm i can understand american football
yeah american football when it's in
and when it's in motion it's like one of
the most exciting sports it just has
too many breaks but sports like baseball
crickets i i i don't understand the
appeal of watching that i really like
the cricket
oh my god i used to like i never watched
baseball
i never watched soccer i always used to
watch the cricket right and if you
thought going to a baseball game was
slow
go to a cricket game well that's like a
four day thing and well
no no no no no no no no no no that's all
i guess no i didn't okay
you're talking about the test cricket
which is like okay like one game is like
five days long okay right they also have
there's three different types i can't
believe i'm gonna talk about qriket
it's very educational
has three different types of games
there's the test cricket which is
the really long one that most people
associate cricket with right yeah yeah
five days no one goes to watch those
right yeah
i mean they do but like you have to be
retired right and have literally nothing
else to do
because it's five days and then there's
the
what they call the one day international
or the odi which is
it it only goes for one day this man
knows his [ __ ] yeah
i mean it's a cricket man and then
there's a shorter version which is
called the 2020
which usually only goes for about three
hours
so it's like it's only three hours it's
speed running qriket
and i and going to watch the 2020 qriket
the short one
is really exciting because they have a
limited number of balls right so they
have no choice but to try and
smack the ball as many times as they
want so it's way more interesting
whereas test cricket
they have five days so they can take
their time
and is it true that after the five days
you can still come out with no winner
yeah there's draw
yeah there's drawers yeah the best
analogy i heard from that is like
imagine having sex for four days and
then in the end nobody comes
that's test qriket that's what it feels
like
but like the test cricket at least in
australia at least in my family
we would put on the test cricket just
like we put it on the tv and then just
have it in the background
and do other stuff around the house so
like every now and then we were coming
to the living room being like oh who's
winnie
like i wouldn't sit in front of the tv
for five days being like
oh my god this is so exciting most of
the time
nothing's happening right edge of your
seat stuff yeah yeah
when i was younger and uh my whole
family likes qriket but i don't like it
and i've made that very clear to them
that i didn't like cricket right
so 13th i'm 13 years old and it's
christmas right
guess what like the main gift they got
me was quick about a ticket to watch the
uh ashes or the ashes the ashes and i
was like
mum i didn't ask for this i asked for
yu-gi-oh cards
it clearly says i know there's no santa
mom come on i'm not putting up with this
act anymore this is [ __ ]
and i'm pretty sure my parents bought me
it just so that my dad could like be
like well if you don't want it
no i didn't i didn't i just had to like
forfeit my main gift which is a ticket
to the ashes yeah
if i were you i would have like gone and
sold that ticket to like a franchise
is going to go to the ashes alone yeah
come on go to the go to the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere in england
watch a game for five days yeah